evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm maria bartiromo
tonight off the rails and broken
promises
joe biden's executive order bonanza has
officially gone
overboard he's likely breaking another
campaign promise along with it
as we all expected him to do of not
raising taxes on anyone making
under four hundred thousand dollars get
ready for the sticker shock
the president signing a record 25 orders
in just his first
nine days in office for context that's
five times as many as president obama
biden's administration is going so crazy
with the orders that even the new york
times is telling joe to knock it off
the executive order hail storm might
come as a surprise to many americans who
heard him say this
on the campaign trail well i got to get
the votes
i got to get the votes i have this
strange notion
we are a democracy some of my republican
friends and some of my democratic
friends even occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator
we're democracy we need consensus
really so what happened to joe biden the
great compromiser the unifier
he used to be known for reaching across
the aisle and working with republicans
now he's just cutting them out the
question is why
the president told us in plain english
today
today i'm about to sign two executive
orders basically the best way to
describe them to undo the damage trump
has done
undo donald trump now he was
specifically talking about today's
actions on obamacare
and abortion there but we can read
between the lines this is the point of
the biden presidency
undo donald trump's legacy at any cost
even if it means doing it alone